so one great example of playful
curiosities can be found in where else
but the bucolic countryside Romania
Media Molecule one of our game
development studios is a team of true
inventive minds they continue to inspire
me with their passion and unique brand
of offbeat creativity they are creating
gaming experiences that are wildly
imaginative their blockbuster title
littlebigplanet introduced an entirely
new different kind of gaming experience
featuring a playful environment built by
the users and encouraging sharing and
connection and the community grew and
today little big planet is inhabited by
millions of people inspired by
participating in the creation of this
whimsical world this game heralded
things to come and today they're
recently released and very highly
acclaimed title called tearaway
validates the power of individual
contributions to the gaming experience a
Media Molecule have been outspoken
advocates for the PlayStation for
calling PlayStation the ultimate
creative console so recently we spent
some time in England capturing the joy
exhilaration and of course the
frustrations and the successes of their
creative process and because as you all
creators know the creative process is
one of the most rewarding yet
challenging professional and artistic
journey so please take a look one of the
things you have to do in any creative
industry and I think in uncreated
industry as well it's the same you have
to have belief you have to want
the genesis of Media Molecule was when
five friends with a huge amount of
experience in the industry walked into a
boardroom at Sony and said hey we want
to make a game about knitting and
buttons and user-generated content
except we didn't even know it was called
that at that point we thought there's no
way that they're going to go for this
creativity is just a fundamental things
we do as humans like there's nothing
special or magical it's not that thing
where you wake up with the cool idea
perhaps that's the starting point but
then you need to take the load ear and
sort of Kindle that flame and then put
huge amounts of effort into seeing that
works if you're not surprised and
stunned by what you've done it's very
unlikely that someone else will just do
do do do do do you do 10 20 things one
of them is gonna be good that's the
attitude and we don't know which one
let's choose together late when you
think this is gonna be cool but I don't
know whether that's going to work then
you're definitely exploring something
that perhaps no one's tried before then
you're innovating you can't ship
something as complicated as a game
without embracing a mixture of iteration
and explosion and evolution and then
sometimes that crazy idea in reality you
need to try things out you'd experiment
and need to fail and one of the most
amazing things about failing is it gives
you a new constraint it's like I went
down that road that road was painful but
that's cool because now you've given
yourself a new kind of wall to push off
love the good as well as the bad because
it might be the bad that actually leads
to something much better where you
thought you were heading in the first
place you need that combination of a
spark of a side waist or or or an
inspiration that you got but then to
combine that with the tenacity to
actually see that through into something
that ships you have to take risks so in
a way leasing a product is a creative
experience in and of itself one of the
beautiful things of working here is that
we get a lot of rope to play with ideas
and
periment but it's grounded in the idea
that in the end it's a commercial
product there has to reach an audience
and that's rewarding I want people to
play our games so that people can enjoy
it on a grand scale so Media Molecule
doesn't exist in a vacuum we exist
within the larger picture of Sony I'm so
lucky that we've been allowed to take
risks in certain key places and the
result is the games that we've made
so as you just saw in that video Media
Molecule is a perfect example of the
type of highly ambitious highly creative
makers of kondal that Wow that we
nurture it Sony